you could like maybe trick people into
thinking you're super healthy and
drinking water all the time but it's
just like [ __ ] coffee
[Music]
wow this literally just looks like a
bottle of water I think if this were a
drink you ordered on an airplane you'd
be really happy to get it cuz it's huge
looks like alcohol oh look at how
British the date is written the other
way I was like nineteen one this is some
future it smells like when I make coffee
at home and then leave the pot to sit
there maybe a little bit like warm
tequila smells like coffee like it
smells like espresso beans but hopefully
it tastes like coffee and we're the kind
of tastes like vaguely have alcohol to
me something is wrong anything
yes it tastes primarily like water that
once touched a coffee bean I actually
like it I really do and I feel more
awake oh it's like a little bit nice cuz
I like water so much that's coffee
that's coffee flavored water it's just
weird that it looks so clear cuz I
really am expecting water
maybe we should I sit and try and put
milk in it and see if it tastes like
what coffee is has anyone done that yet
oh it's kind of cool actually does not
make it taste any different I'm a person
that really likes black coffee without
any sugar and stuff so this to me is
like this is dope
it works for you man go for it clear
coffee I don't know it's not for me I'm
gonna stick with my normal coffee I do
know a lot of people who refuse to drink
coffee without a straw because they're
worried of staining their teeth that's
probably who it's for which is stupid
just to live your [ __ ] life
right
[Music]